DON’T YET KNOW ABOUT THAT TRAIN,
MAKING IT PRETTY SCARY.
JOINING US NOW, PRESIDENT
BIDEN’S CHIEF MEDICAL ADVISER,
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI.
WELCOME TO "AMERICA REPORTS."
GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Sandra: FIRST OFF, THE NEW
STRAIN, WE’RE TALKING TO THE
AUDIENCE ABOUT IT.
HOW DEADLY IS IT?
ARE WE ABLE TO DETECT IT AND IS
IT GROWING IN NUMBERS?
>> WHICH ONE ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
I JUST SAT DOWN.
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THE SOUTH
AFRICAN ONE?
>> Sandra: THAT’S THE PROBLEM.
WHICH ONE.
LET START WITH THE U.K., AND
THEN SOUTH AFRICA.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO BE WORRIED
ABOUT AS AMERICANS?
WHAT IS HERE NOW?
>> WE NEED TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
THE U.K. STRAIN, WHICH IS ONE
WITH A CERTAIN SET OF MUTATIONS
IS ALREADY IN 25 OR MORE STATES
IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT HAS BEEN SHOWN ACCORDING TO
THE WORK THAT WE’RE DOING BY OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE U.K. TO BE
MORE TRANSMISSABLE, MORE EASY TO
TRANSMIT.
THEY SAID IT WAS NOT MORE LETHAL
NAMELY IT DIDN’T CAUSE ON A
PERSON-TO-PERSON BASIS MORE
SERIOUS DISEASE.
BUT THEY CAME OUT WITH NEW DATA
THAT INDICATES THE U.K. STRAIN
MIGHT IN FACT BE A BIT MORE
DEADLY THAN WHAT WE CALL THE
WILD-TYPE STRAIN.
WITH REGARD TO THE VACCINES,
DOES NOT SEEM TO BE ANY NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON THE U.K. STRAIN.
THEY’VE BEEN USED FOR TREATMENT
AND PREVENTION.
DON’T WORK AS WELL AS THAT
STRAIN.
IT IS DIMINISHED SOMEWHAT THE
CAPABILITY OF THE VACCINE TO
PROTECT, BUT AND THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BUT, THE VACCINE STILL
IS EFFECTIVE AGAINST THIS STRAIN
THAT IS IN SOUTH AFRICA.
HAVING SAID THAT, WE NEED TO TRY
AND STAY A FEW STEPS AHEAD OF
THE GAME SO WE ALREADY ARE
PREPARING IN CASE THAT MUTANT A
GETS HERE, WHICH IT MIGHT BE
HERE.
IN CASE IT GETS DOCUMENTED TO BE
AND WE NEED TO BE PREPARED TO
UPGRADE THE VACCINE TO ALLOW IT
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT.
RIGHT NOW THE VACCINES LOOK FINE
AGAINST BOTH THE U.K. AND THE
SOUTH AFRICAN STRAIN.
>> John: DR. FAUCI, YOU SAID IN
THE LAST COUPLE DAYS WHEN IT
COMES TO THE VACCINE, SUPPLY
WILL NOT MEET THE DEMAND, WHICH
IS LANGUAGE THAT IS A LOT
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE SAW JUST
A FEW MONTHS AGO IN THE CLOSING
DAYS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU WERE PART OF IT BACK THEN.
I DON’T WANT TO GO BACK AND
REHASH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT I’D LIKE TO KNOW, WAS THERE
A NUMBER OF MONTHS AGO A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN DEVELOPED BY
THE WHITE HOUSE TO DISTRIBUTE
THIS VACCINE?
BECAUSE A FORMER OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION IS SAYING THAT
THINGS WERE A MESS WHEN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TOOK OVER.
IF THEY WERE A MESS, YOU WERE
PART OF THAT TEAM.
SO WHAT WAS IN PLACE AT THAT
TIME?
>> YEAH, WELL, JOHN, I REALLY
DON’T WANT TO GO BACK AND REHASH
THAT.
THAT IS NOT PRODUCTIVE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT PART OF
OPERATION WARP SPEED WAS A PLAN
TO BE ABLE TO GET VACCINE IN
WHAT GENERAL PERNATHAT WAS IN
CHARGE OF THAT, GET IT OUT IN A
CADENCE OF GETTING THE VACCINE
OUT, GETTING IT SHIPPED, GETTING
IT DISTRIBUTED AND GETTING IT IN
TO THE PLACES WHERE IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE.
IN THE BEGINNING, THERE WAS SOME
MISSTEPS THERE BECAUSE THERE WAS
A DISCREPANCY ABOUT WHAT WAS
GOING OUT AND WHAT WAS GETTING
INTO PEOPLE’S ARMS.
SO RIGHT NOW WHAT WE’RE TRYING
TO DO IS TO GET A BROADER PLAN.
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS DID HAPPEN
WITH OPERATION WARP SPEED.
LET’S LOOK FORWARD ABOUT WHAT
THE PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT BIDEN,
HAS SAID, HOW WE’RE GOING TO GET
AS MANY DOSES IN AS MANY PEOPLE
AS WE CAN.
THAT’S WHY WE HAVE HIS PLAN.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE, IT’S A
FLAW, NOT A CEILING TO GET 100
MILLION DOSES IN TO PEOPLE IN
THE FIRST 100 DAYS.
>> Sandra: DR. FAUCI, ON THAT
NOTE, IT BOGGLES MANY WHEN YOU
SEE THE DECISIONS THAT GOVERNORS
ARE MAKING ON CLOSURES.
IN NEW YORK CITY, THE POSITIVITY
RATE IS BELOW 1%.
ALMOST 75% OF HOSPITAL WORKERS
HAVE RECEIVED THE VACCINE.
BUT YET THE GOVERNOR HAS NOT
INDICATED THAT HE’S GOING TO
REOPEN RESTAURANTS FOR IN-PERSON
DINING.
AS YOU HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED, THIS
IS INCREDIBLE PAIN ON SMALL
BUSINESSES, RESTAURANTEURS THAT
CAN’T OPERATE THEIR BUSINESSES
INSIDE WHEN IT’S 20 DEGREES AND
SNOWING OUT.
DO YOU SEE ANY REASON WHY THE
NEW YORK GOVERNOR SHOULDN’T
ALLOW FOR IN-PERSON DINING TO
REOPEN WITH THOSE STATISTICS?
>> YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO TELL YOU,
I’M NOT GOING TO BE OUT HERE
OUTGETTING A GOVERNOR WHO IS ON
THE GROUND IN HIS OR HER OWN
STATE --
>> Sandra: THOSE ARE HIS
STATISTICS.
>> WE’RE NOT GOING THERE.
I’M NOT OUT GUESSING --
>> Sandra: TYPE.
SO YOU DON’T WANT TO GO THERE.
WHAT ABOUT SCHOOL CLOSURES?
CHICAGO WON’T REOPEN THEIR
SCHOOLS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT KIDS ARE NOT
PASSING THE DISEASE IN THE
CLASSROOMS WHEN THEY’RE
FOLLOWING CDC GUIDELINES.
SHOULDN’T THEY REOPEN SCHOOLS IN
CHICAGO, FOR EXAMPLE?
>> WHAT I’M GOING TO TELL YOU
ARE THE GENERAL PRINCIPLES AND
EACH INDIVIDUAL STATE, WITH
THEIR GOVERNOR, CITY WITH THEIR
MAYOR WILL MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS.
LET ME FINISH.
LET ME COMMENT, SEE IF I CAN
HELP YOU OUT TO UNDERSTAND THE
BIGGER PICTURE.
YES, I UNDERSTAND GREATLY THE
STRAIN THAT IS ON LOCAL
BUSINESSES AND RESTAURANTS AND
OTHERS, THAT THAT’S THE REASON
WHY WE NEED HELP.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET
RESOURCES THAT IF INDOOR DINING
IS GOING TO BE PROHIBITED, WE
HAVE TO HAVE HELP TO THE OWNERS
OF THOSE ORGANIZATIONS SO THEY
DON’T GO UNDER DURING A PERIOD
OF TIME WHEN WE’RE TRYING TO
CORRECT AND GET OUR ARMS AND
THIS OUTBREAK.
>> Sandra: WE’RE SUPPOSED TO BE
FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE.
THAT’S THE PROBLEM.
SCIENCE SAYS THAT KIDS CAN
SAFELY BE BACK IN THE CLASSROOM
IF THEY’RE FOLLOWING CDC
GUIDANCE?
>> WHAT THE SCIENCE TELLS US IS
THE FOLLOWING.
CHILDREN IN SCHOOL RIGHT NOW IT
APPEARS THAT IF YOU FOLLOW THE
SAFETY GUIDELINES OF THE CDC,
THAT THEY ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE
GETTING INFECTED THAN THE
COMMUNITY RATE OF INFECTION.
THAT IS THE REASON WHY AS
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS SAID, WE’RE
GOING TO TRY AS BEST AS WE CAN
WITHIN THE FRAME WORK OF
FOLLOWING THE CDC GUIDELINES TO
GET CHILDREN BACK TO SCHOOL.
I’VE BEEN SAYING THAT FOR MONTHS
AND MONTHS.
THAT THE DEFAULT POSITION SHOULD
BE TO THE BEST OF OUR ABILITY
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES TO THE
LOCAL AREAS SO THAT CHILDREN CAN
GET BACK TO SCHOOL PROVIDED THEY
HAVE FUNDAMENTAL SAFETY MEASURES
LIKE MASK WEARING AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
THAT MAY REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
>> John: THE DEFAULT POSITION,
DR. FAUCI, OF THE TEACHERS
UNIONS WE’RE NOT GOING BACK
UNTIL THERE’S GUARANTEED SAFETY.
THAT DISCUSSION DOESN’T FALL
INTO YOUR AREA OF PURVIEW.
BUT WHAT DOES, IS THE W.H.O.,
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
YOU ADDRESSED THEM LAST WEEK.
YOU SAID THE UNITED STATES WAS
REENTERING THE W.H.O.
YOU HAVE ALSO SAID THAT THE
UNITED STATES IS GOING TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE
VACCINE-SHARING PROGRAM WITH THE
W.H.O.
SO A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
FIRST OF ALL, WHEN IT COMES TO
THE W.H.O., ARE YOU CERTAIN THAT
THEY’RE OPERATING AS AN
INDEPENDENT BODY AND NOT ON
BEHALF OF CHINA AS ALLEGED BY
THE LAST ADMINISTRATION AND
SECONDLY, ENTERING THE VACCINE
SHARING PROGRAM, WHAT EFFECT
WILL THAT HAVE ON THE UNITED
STATES’ ABILITY TO GET VACCINES
OUT TO PEOPLE WHEN WE’RE ALREADY
HAVING PROBLEMS DOING THAT?
>> JOHN, THANK YOU FOR POSING
THE QUESTION IN THAT WAY AND
HOPEFULLY I’LL GIVE YOU A CLEAR
EXPLANATION.
IF YOU LISTENED, WHICH I THINK
YOU DID BUT NOT EVERYBODY HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CAREFULLY
LOOK AT THE WORDS WHEN I MADE
THE ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WE WILL BE
REJOINING THE WHO.
AT LEAST TWICE DURING THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT, I MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT WE WOULD EXPECT
REFORMS IN WHO.
WE WOULD TAKE THE REFORMS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
NEXT WE SAID WE WERE VERY MUCH
IN FAVOR OF THE INVESTIGATION OF
THE ORIGINS OF THIS VIRUS.
SO ALTHOUGH WE WILLINGLY SAID
THAT WE WANT TO REJOIN THE WHO
AND BE PART OF THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY, WE MADE IT VERY CLEAR
AND I WAS REPRESENTING THE
PRESIDENT ON THAT ANNOUNCEMENT,
THAT REFORMS ARE GOING TO BE
TAKEN VERY SERIOUSLY BY US.
SO THAT ANSWERS YOUR FIRST
QUESTION.
NOW, I FORGOT YOUR SECOND
>> John: IT WAS ON JOINING THE
WHO’S VACCINE-SHARING PROGRAM.
GETTING VACCINES TO AMERICANS,
IF WE JOIN THE VACCINE-SHARING
PROGRAM, WILL THAT EXACERBATE
THE PROBLEM?
>> THANKS FOR ASKING THE
QUESTION.
WHEN WE SAY WE’RE JOINING COVAC,
WE’RE NOT SAYING WE’RE GIVING
THEM ALLOCATIONS THAT WERE OUR
ALLOCATIONS.
WE SAID WE WOULD PARTICIPATE IN
MAKING SURE THAT THERE’S SOME
EQUITY GLOBALLY FOR COUNTRIES
THAT CAN’T AFFORD IT.
THERE’S A NUMBER OF WAYS OF
DOING THAT.
ONE IS TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO THE PROGRAM TO
DEVELOP VACCINES FROM OTHER
COMPANIES OR EVEN THE COMPANIES
THAT WE’RE DEALING WITH SO WE’LL
BE ABLE TO GET VACCINE DOSES TO
THEM.
IT DOESN’T MEAN WE’RE GOING TO
TAKE THE VACCINE DOSES THAT WERE
ALLOCATED TO US AND GIVE TO
THEM.
THE OTHER THING IS, IF IT TURNS
OUT THAT IN OUR CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP WE OVERSHOOT AND WE
HAVE EVEN MORE VACCINE THAN WE
CAN USE, THERE’S ALWAYS THE
CONSIDERATION --
>> Sandra: THAT WOULD BE A NICE
PROBLEM TO HAVE.
>> THAT WOULD BE.
BUT THAT IS CONCEIVABLE THAT
THAT WOULD HAPPEN.
SO JUST MAKE SURE THAT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC DOESN’T
INTERPRET THAT WE’LL TAKE
VACCINE THAT WAS READY TO GO TO
NEW YORK AND CHICAGO AND GIVE IT
TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
THAT’S NOT WHAT WE’RE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> Sandra: DR. FAUCI, SEEMS LIKE
THE GOAL POSTS KEEP MOVING.
WE KNOW CALIFORNIA IS HAVING
PROBLEMS.
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT ADDITIONAL
STRAINS.
ALL OF US ARE TRYING TO DO WHAT
IT TAKES TO STAY SAFE.
WE ALL WEAR OUR MASKS AND HOPE
THAT MOST PEOPLE ARE.
NOW WE’RE HEARING WE SHOULD WEAR
TWO.
IF I GO TO THE GROCERY STORE, DO
I WEAR TWO OR THREE OR SAFER TO
WEAR EIGHTH?
WHERE DOES IT STOP?
>> THE DISCUSSION IS CHANGING,
NOT THE GOAL POSTS.
SO THE CDC DOESN’T OFFICIALLY
RECOMMEND WEARING DOUBLE MASKS.
WHAT THEY’RE SAYING IS YOU KNOW
WHAT WOULD BE A GOOD START?
IF EVERYBODY WEARS AT LEAST ONE
MASK.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT.
SO THE CDC RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE
NOT CHANGED.
WHAT WE’RE TRYING TO DO IS TO
GET INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE NOT
WEARING MASKS TO WEAR MASKS.
>> John: DR. FAUCI, CAN I GET
ONE QUICK ANSWER TO THE
FOLLOWING QUESTIONS?
GOVERNOR CUOMO OF NEW YORK SAID
TODAY THAT IT’S GOING TO TAKE
SIX TO NINE MONTHS TO GET
EVERYBODY VACCINATED OR TO THE
POINT OFHEAD IMMUNEITY BUT HE
CAN’T WAIT THAT LONG TO OPEN THE
ECONOMY BACK UP.
COMPETING PRESSURES HERE.
WHAT DO YOU SUGGEST?
>> YOU DON’T NECESSARILY HAVE TO
HAVE AN ALL-OR-NONE PHENOMENON.
I SPEAK WITH GOVERNOR CUOMO
FREQUENTLY.
HE’S TRYING TO BALANCE WHAT IS
BEST FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
AT THE SAME TIME ADDRESSING THE
SERIOUS IMPACT THAT IT WOULD
HAVE ON THE ECONOMY OF NEW YORK
STATE AND NEW YORK CITY
OBVIOUSLY AS AN IMPORTANT PART
OF NEW YORK STATE.
WHAT ONE CAN DO IS YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO THE AMOUNT OF
INFECTION AT THE SAME TIME OF
GRADUALLY OPENING UP THE
ECONOMY.
SO YOU WEARING A MASK, KEEPING
DISTANCE, AVOIDING CONGREGATE
SETTINGS, WASHING HANDS, YOU CAN
HAVE A GREAT IMPACT ON THE
DYNAMICS OF THE OUTBREAK AND DO
THAT AT THE SAME TIME THAT
YOU’RE GRADUALLY OPENING YOUR
ECONOMY.
QUITE FRANKLY, JOHN, THAT’S WHAT
WE SAID MONTHS AND MONTHS AGO
WHEN WE TRIED TO REOPEN THE
ECONOMY WITH THE GUIDELINES THAT
WE PUT OUT.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY WERE NOT
UNIFORMLY FOLLOWED.
>> Sandra: FINAL FINAL.
REAL QUICK.
YOU TALKED TO GOVERNOR CUOMO
OFTEN.
SO IF HE CALLED YOU TODAY AND
SAID I HAVE A POSITIVITY RATE
BELOW 1%, I’VE GOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE VACCINATED, DO YOU THINK
IT’S SAFE TO REOPEN AT LEAST FOR
25% CAPACITY IN-PERSON DINING?
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL HIM?
>> YOU KNOW, I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR MORE ABOUT WHAT’S GOING ON
WITH THE DYNAMICS.
AGAIN, YOU DON’T MAKE POLICY IN
A CONVERSATION LIKE YOU AND I.
WHAT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO DO IS
AFTER I HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
THE GOVERNOR, THEN TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THE THINGS WE DISCUSSED.
I DON’T WANT TO DO IT BEFORE
I --
>> Sandra: I APPRECIATE IT.
THANKS, DR. FAUCI.
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
QUESTIONS.
>> John: YOU DON’T LAST AS LONG
AS HE HAS IN HIS POSITION WHEN